was für eine stolze woche für unser land
ein deutscher wird kommandant der
raumstation iss alexander gerst ist
großartig oder herzlichen glückwunsch
klitzekleiner verbesserungsvorschlag
wenn wir schon einen alexander ins all
schießen hätte man nicht auch alexander
gauland leben ist jetzt keine kritik
also nur als idee alexander pack die
badehose ein gau land hat es wieder
einmal geschafft die grenzen des
sagbaren in seinem sinne jahre ein wenig
zu denen wobei man fairerweise sagen
muss viele männer in seinem alter haben
ja nur noch zwei themen stuhlgang und
hitler
aber liebe freunde hitler und die nazis
sind nur ein falsches über 1000 jahre
erfolgreich und deutsche mit ja
da hilft es auch nicht
[Applaus]
wenn man lieblingskinderbuch da hilft es
auch nichts wenn man vorher murmelt wir
übernehmen irgendwie verantwortung für
diese zwölf jahre über 50 millionen tote
ein vogel schiff und trotzdem glauben
millionen von lebenden deutschen das die
afd eine ganz normale bürgerliche partei
ist das was die schuldkult nennen muss
weg damit man wieder unbeschwert
nationalist sein kann und wer sie dafür
kritisiert
er hat unser lot mich liebt die liebe
nicht diese sind sie lieben ist einfach
nicht die bestimmen nämlich wer
deutschland liebt und wer nicht wir
sehen das mal aufgefallen die afg hat
uns allen den patriotismus geklaut ja
und die fahne
ich wette mit ihnen es gibt inzwischen
junge menschen jugendliche die denken
dass hier wäre eine fc fahne
warum gibt es keine deutschland fahren
bei gegendemos das frage ich mich
ernsthaft die rechten sollen gefälligst
wieder mit reichskriegsflagge gehen
wartet man da fehlt noch was herr vogel
schießt jetzt basteln
ja
[Applaus]
doch nicht
und sind dabei sehr liebe nicht dieses
land baulands geheule hat wenn man genau
hinhört schon fast was melodisches nicht
die liebe nicht das volk und die liebe
nicht seine kultur und geschichte
eine zuwanderungs gesellschaft sie
lieben die freundin nicht uns nicht mit
deutschen denen dieses land
[Applaus]
h
wer sie lieben muss nicht remix von dj
doppelherz können sie sich als
schellackplatte downloaden übrigens
während er seinen hit performt hat hing
vor der bühne dieses plakat stoppt den
genozid an den deutschen ja wir wollen
die geschichte umdrehen
diese partei radikalisiert sich in
lichtgeschwindigkeit wenn man genau
hinguckt so hat zum beispiel die junge
alternative kurz jk
die heißt so bei ihrem bundeskongress
auf sicher einfach mal alle drei
strophen des deutschlandliedes
geschmettert und jetzt raten sie doch
mal wer bei diesem kongress der absolute
star gast war richtig der bär
denn
[Applaus]